let's start today with the Twitter files
there's a growing story being told by
those on the right in the Maga crowd and
elsewhere that the left whoever that is
supposed to mean is quote ignoring the
Twitter files which some are calling
orwellian and one of the greatest
stories about censorship and uh
Injustice towards right-wing
perspectives in decades or something and
I want to go through this and really
break it down into its component parts
the first question is whether the left
and let's pretend we know exactly what
they mean by that the left is ignoring
it that is absolutely untrue and in fact
you can I can I can really only speak
for myself and others that I am I'm sort
of aware of but we've all been talking
about it and you can find numerous
stories about the Twitter files on my
YouTube channel and our podcast archives
Etc now invariably
the people who first say David you've
been ignoring it will see the things
I've said and they said well you're
ignoring the main point which is that
Twitter and Biden and big Tech censor
the right and then also try to help the
left by preventing negative story well
so it's not that I'm ignoring it it's
that you don't like the conclusion I've
come to so let's talk about the reality
of the Twitter files if you are media
literate and internet literate and you
look at this story
and you look at the facts you realize
there is practically nothing there now I
won't say nothing there I I say
practically nothing there and we'll get
to what there is there but this Twitter
file story
is fundamentally a grievance Story the
type of grieving story that the right
loves to say the left is obsessed with
the right love to say the left is all
about grievance culture I've been
wronged because of my race and I've been
wrong because of my gender and I've been
wrong because you know whatever fill in
the blanks this is the story that the
right loves to tell and they say the
left's got to move on from Grievances
and get something done this is a
grieving story that's what this is and
it's a grieving story comprised of out
of context anecdotes to point to a
heavily biased conclusion supported by
incomplete data
at best and that's like the most
charitable analysis that I can give the
narrative that has been presented
doesn't actually align with the content
of the Twitter files and there's a
disconnect here that has left a lot of
people wondering why aren't the Twitter
files being treated as a bigger deal
there's a mainstream media blackout on
the Twitter files and left-wing media
you won't talk about it initially the
story about the Twitter files was
supposed to be government is censoring
big tech companies and big tech
companies are censoring the right and
helping the left eventually it was
revealed Twitter was making its own
decisions about content on its platform
which the right has previously defended
their right to do
as a private company and the government
by which they actually mean the Biden
Campaign which wasn't even the
government at the time
was uh calling to the attention of
Twitter content they believed violate
Twitter's violated Twitter's terms of
service which it did of nude images of
Hunter Biden now
another aspect to the story was the
Biden again they called it the Biden
Administration but it was it was 2020
there was no Biden Administration the
Biden Administration was forcing the
removal of content related to Hunter
Biden we later discovered that the Biden
team was initially just using the normal
methods to report content and later had
email contacts that they could use at
Twitter to say hey we believe this
violates your terms of service
importantly
the Trump campaign the Trump
Administration also had access to the
very same people at Twitter via email so
it was not unique to the Biden campaign
and at the end of the day with the Biden
team was asking to have removed was
content that was illegal in Most states
and violated Twitter's own terms of
service it's sometimes called revenge
porn I understand that that term is uh
problematic to some because porn makes
it sound like it's consensual these were
explicit and obscene I don't know what
type of explicit images uh that were
released without the consent of Hunter
Biden right that's what we're talking
about that's what this was fundamentally
about it deflated the entire story
the story was also supposed to be about
the Trump White House trying to demand
that content be removed
and that is largely being ignored the
people on the right that are saying the
story is about Hunter Biden exclusively
ignore that the Trump White House
Government and administration also had
the same access that the Biden campaign
had and they would ask for content to
remove and they're not talking about
that they want to ignore that part of it
because it doesn't fit the narrative
that they want you to believe and then
lastly we were told well the FBI is
telling Twitter what to censor
turns out that wasn't true turns out the
FBI shared information with Twitter
about potential sources of
disinformation and ultimately Twitter
made its own determinations now you
would say Well when the FBI comes to you
and says hey here's here's information
the FBI wants you to do something but as
the Twitter files have come out it
doesn't actually appear that that was
the case it appears that Twitter was
able to decide on its own genuinely
decide on its own what to remove and
what not to remove so the the
unfortunate part for the right is that
the Twitter files didn't live up to the
hype the Twitter files don't actually
confirm the initial narrative that was
presented to them instead they have
become sort of a cudgel for the right
and Elon Musk and Matt taibi and the
other people Bari Weiss to spin a story
and drive a narrative but the efforts
have largely failed they want to say
we presented the bombshell and it is a
bombshell and the left and mainstream
media won't talk about it because of
their bias the reality is they failed to
actually present the bombshell they
claim this to be so people are sort of
looking at it and saying oh there's not
really a very big story here and what
you will often find is that those who
claim it's a very big story when you
actually say to them which part is the
bombshell they go well the Biden
Administration was uh it was 2020 there
was no Biden Administration well they
were censoring the hunter but well we're
talking about explicit images released
without his consent they're illegal in
Most states and violate Twitter's terms
okay well so and then there's nothing
left there's just nothing left so the
question really becomes how much do you
expect quote the left
to talk about a story that isn't
anywhere near what it was supposed to be
you've got people cherry-picking details
and spinning them to fit a narrative
that has largely Fallen apart and
downplaying the parts that are
inconvenient like the fact that the
actual Trump administration had the very
same access to Twitter terms of service
and content moderation people last thing
the Twitter files are part of a larger
puzzle it's a piece of a larger puzzle
and we shouldn't ascribe more
significance to the Twitter files in the
broader context of the story when we
talk about the state of media and
politics and speech and censorship and
all these different things there is a
big story there and it's about the
unmitigated spread of disinformation on
Facebook particularly among older folks
the use of Twitter by white nationality
there's there's tons of story there
really is a story there
but what the Twitter files is is a
little tiny piece of it that is out of
context and also being inaccurately
reported and so for the people that are
insisting that the Twitter files are one
of the greatest and most orwellian
stories of manipulation of the public
it's hyperbole it's sensationalism it's
not a fair and balanced approach to the
facts we should talk about and be aware
about media bias we should be aware of
propaganda manipulation censorship but
we've got to be critical and objective
and if you're critical and objective and
you actually look at the claims that
were initially made and what was
actually revealed by the Twitter files
you realize that there's very little
there what you could say and this is
when we get back to is there a
legitimate story
You could argue You could argue that
neither the Trump Administration nor the
Biden campaign
should have been able to email anyone at
Twitter to say we believe this violates
her terms of service you could make the
case
they should have to just use the report
feature like everybody else that's the
one thing you could argue but if you
want to argue that you have to apply it
not only to the Biden campaign but also
to the Trump White House and I'm not
seeing anybody do that
one of our sponsors is all form the
easiest way to design your own custom
sofa I have one from all form unlike
other companies all form lets you choose
the fabric the size the shape color even
the color of the legs I have not one but
two all form sofas I've had them for
years they look good as new definitely
the most comfortable Furniture I own and
it gets even cooler because all form
sofas are completely modular you can buy
a sofa and if you move you can adapt it
to the new space by adding on to it or
rearranging its elements that is
definitely not something you get from
your typical Sofa Company all form has
everything from eight piece sectionals
to love seats and arm chairs everything
is made in the USA using premium
materials all form makes sure that
assembly is really easy I didn't even
need any tools which is good because I
have very few tools and you can keep the
sofa for over three months and send it
back free if you don't like it for a
full refund right now all form is giving
my audience 20 off all orders at
allform.com Pacman the link is down
below